police reinforcements have been sent to
West Papua to control protests that have
turned violent government buildings
police cars and parts of an airports
have been destroyed the police have been
accused of racism after 43 Paquin
students were arrested for disrespecting
the Indonesian flag on Independence Day
there were reports one flag was set
alight outside a dormitory after being
held for hours the students were
released without charge the government
regrets the burning of the Indonesian
flag the incident is under investigation
the incident was followed by negative
statements which triggered violence
several areas of Papua and West Papua
provinces it is disrupting the nation's
unity the protests came after videos
were shared on social media showing a
school being tear gassed and the
students called monkeys a derogatory
term used against ethnic pop ones for
years Indonesia has blamed indigenous
Pupkin separatists for unrest in the
West Papua new agent but they accused
the government of human rights abuses
during protests on Tuesday 258 inmates
escaped from the prison in the city of
Sarang after it was set on fire the
city's mayor called for calm come on
let's join handing hand together United
in our hearts leave our differences in
maintained togetherness unity and
solidarity between pop ones or non pop
ones Deniz Ian president Joko Widodo
says he's committed to the welfare of
all pup ones but it's not clear if his
words will be enough to calm protesters
they're now calling for a referendum on
independence Sora hi dad and Jazeera